you know I hear you're a master of
Impressions what would grank say about
Travis Kelsey and Taylor swill yo Jules
can you believe that Kelsey and Swift
are together that's pretty cool what
would Bill bich say if you sent him a
birthday present look Jules like I hope
you don't think that I'm going to get
you a present now what the what would
Tom Brady say if you invite him on a
vacation look babe I got my kids in in
Miami in New York babe I I'm probably
not going to be able to make it babe
sorry babe I love you babe what Randy
mon say if someone just got mous edel
nut you know that song A Star is Born
today that song was made when I was born
and now they saying this about me 98
first round get to know me what would
Von Miller say after second Tom Brady yo
Brady you can call me Vonnie I only let
the ladies call it to me usually but I
love you man bro you're a master of
absolutely I'm terrible at impressions